hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint vite sur
messenger est ce que voulaient découvrir
les premiers tuto botha smit père dont
il donne ses conseils nous avez appris à
danser maintenant il nous apprend à se
maquiller à prendre soin de nous ces
partis regarde beaucoup les putschistes
étaient pas sioniste hausse
vous l'avez voulue et bien vous l'avez
eue premier tuto de beauté pour je sais
pas peut-être un jour être comme moi
allez tout de suite les accessoires
waouh lots gloria de leurs mots styles
et pour ce premier tutoriel
il faut quoi un boy's walkom gaming
ballade you see you revolver allez c'est
parti pour ce premier tuto beauté on
attaque avec la crème des prénoms
camille bellagio allez c'est parti on y
va on n'a pas peur on applique
généreusement olala on y va
et on remonte on remonte très important
contre la gravité on remonte contre la
gravité et on tapote went away
ce que je vois je vois ce que j'aime
voilà bravo monkam de leurs moustaches
deuxième et accessoires très important
lapin ça et il est pareil quand on se
regarde le style tac tac tac
ouais de leurs moustaches et pendant que
les crèmes applique qu est-ce qu on
ferme perd jamais son temps un beau
visage mais aussi un beau fessier aller
entre tourne et on le bot ce fessiers on
le boss on l'aisne en laine c'est son
meilleur ami et voilà qui rit mort au
style jeu tekken de l'homme au style
vous avez la crème vous avez la pince à
épiler
vous avez la volonté alors c'est parti
j'appelle ma gloria où elle comme ma
belle
on y va 3 2 1 c'est parti
m
[Musique]
non
mais comme les boys regardez gloria
avant et regardez le maintenant voilà
c'était notre premier plutôt de deux
hommes au style et n'oubliez pas le
montrait beaucoup plus beau s'il
ressembler à moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]